yo tendría que estar muerto hace 30 años
soy un sobreviviente
uno de los miles de conscriptos
argentinos soldados no profesionales que
fuimos enviados a una guerra que nunca
debía ocurrir
pase 60 días sobreviviendo en un pozo
congelado en condiciones infrahumanas
junto a mi compañero roberto
sin alimentación sólida y perdí 20 kilos
de peso corporal
tuvimos claramente tres enemigos
el clima los ingleses y tristemente
nuestros propios jefes que nos trataron
con un desprecio por la condición humana
que nos costaba entender
claro antes
panorama
tan tan duro
donde no sabíamos si vamos a sobrevivir
a esa desnutrición y esos maltratos
empezaron a surgir fortalezas no sé de
dónde
empezamos a tomar decisiones a tomar
decisiones para no morirnos no era mucho
lo que podíamos hacer pero empezamos a
hacerlo a trabajar en el día a día
cosas simples como mantener ese pozo lo
menos mojado posible
también escaparnos al vuelo 10 km a
tratar de revolver los tachos de basura
de los isleños o romper algún galpón
desesperados y 10 km de vuelta eso lo
dejamos hacer rápido porque por dos
motivos
el gasto calórico era enorme y
conseguíamos pocas cosas y los castigos
eran inhumanos
si no se encontraban nos destacaban en
esta que era una crucifixión al suelo
atados de muñecas y tobillos con la
campera abierta
como animales durante horas había por lo
menos 15 o 20 de mis compañeros en esas
condiciones
por ir a robar comida
esta foto que es muy impresionante
son mis mis hermanos sobrevivientes de
la compañía de ellos bailaron con la más
fea ellos recibieron lo peor del ataque
fantasmas los compañeros del pueblo que
nos veían en esas condiciones no después
años más tarde nos enteramos que nos
decían los zombis
todos pero estos sobrevivientes y todos
hermanos
aprendí muchas cosas
con esa experiencia aprendí a ser más
humilde aprendí
a escuchar y a pedir ser escuchado
aprendí a valorar cada cosa con mucha
intensidad
y sobre todo
empecé a descubrir fortalezas que ni
imaginaba que yo mismo tenía
pero hablando de aprendizajes
uno de los aprendizajes más interesantes
ocurrió a la vuelta cuando los ingleses
nos llevan como prisioneros de guerra en
este transatlántico el canberra rumbo
madryn hay pase una semana a bordo de
esa nave y yo era traductor
y lo que pasó ahí fue como un alucinante
experimento antropológico
4122 prisioneros argentinos que veníamos
custodiados por los mismos ingleses con
los que habíamos estado matando nos la
semana anterior
era una experiencia surrealista y yo
pensé antes de subir al barco cuando me
tenía que estaban los ingleses dije
listo acá se pudre todo nos matamos a
trompadas
pero mi sorpresa fue grande cuando me
encuentro al poco tiempo traduciendo
conversaciones entre mis compañeros
argentinos y los ingleses
estas conversaciones amables
conversaciones con mucha curiosidad
acerca de cómo había sido el otro lado
conversaciones de música escuchábamos
pink floyd y genes y nosotros ellos
también y en el barco en la música era
era eso lo que se escuchaba en los
parlantes
y ahí aprendí una enorme lección aprendí
que sería imposible enfrentar a un
enemigo una vez que después lo conoce
que uno lo conoce una vez que el enemigo
deja de ser anónimo
y que los enemigos son siempre anónimos
y que también pensé que si uno pusiera a
convivir a grupos de jóvenes en países
en conflicto y que esos jóvenes se
conozcan y dialoguen como hicimos
ingleses y argentinos a bordo de ese
barco
habría quizás menos guerras en el mundo
y menos jóvenes ingresando ejércitos
las tareas a bordo del barco fueron
intensas yo recorría el barco
traduciendo y
a esta tareas en quirófanos que fueron
este muy impresionantes
yo yo tape la historia cuando volví de
la guerra tape y no hable durante 20
años fue recién en 2001 con la crisis la
catástrofe argentina de 2001 yo tenía
una actividad comercial un negocio en la
ciudad de venado tuerto santa fe y donde
vivo y estaba como millones de
argentinos sufriendo un estrés
impresionante y en ese marco tengo mi
primer pesadilla de combate nunca había
soñado
hay sueño que estoy en un pozo junto a
cinco compañeros la mañana del 12 de
junio los ingleses ya habían tomado la
cima y nos están lloviendo toneladas de
fierro caliente morterazos y cañones y
todo está temblando como un terremoto
tenemos dos amigos muertos afuera que no
alcanzaron a entrar tenemos a roberto
con esquirlas en cadera intestino
la aceleración final de esos proyectiles
es estremecedora yo yo empiezo a rezar
todo esto está durando 8 horas de 8 de
la mañana a 4 de la tarde
las sensaciones como que están cayendo
vehículos del cielo
y no paraba de temblar y yo empiezo a
rezar como despidiendo en este mundo mis
amigos me acompañan
y mientras estoy rezando me vienen en
cámara lenta imágenes de mi familia
jugando con mi abuela y con mi vieja
y en esa instancia dentro de la
pesadilla me suena un teléfono celular
era el gerente del banco que me decía a
mi gente cierra la cuenta tienes
demasiados cheques rechazados
ese día
me di cuenta que no podía seguir tapando
pedí ayuda empecé a hablar los primeros
dos años con tratamiento psicológico
después hablar y bueno y terminé
escribiendo un libro
pero los recuerdos y la pesadilla no
vino sola vino acompañada de todos los
desórdenes por este es postraumático que
uno puede imaginar estuve muy deprimido
perdí mucho peso y estuve dos años con
imágenes invasivas recuerdos recurrentes
que no paraban de venir a mi mente
pero al igual que en el pozo donde con
roberto empezamos a tomar decisiones en
el día a día yo en esa instancia donde
pensé que me estaba volviendo loco
empecé también a trabajar en el día a
día y estar mejor las cosas que hice
pueden parecer hasta graciosas yo
lloraba a la mañana
y hasta tuve sueños donde me suicidaba y
en esos momentos me esforzaba a
levantarme de la cama a salir a correr a
nadar clases de teatro masajes reiki
flores de bach hasta cura sanador
pero al final del día me di cuenta al
igual que en el pozo que las riendas de
mi vida las tenía que tener yo y fue así
como gradualmente me fui empezando a
sentir mejor sabía qué
dentro de ese camino sanador que yo
tenía que empezar a recorrer que ya
había empezado a recorrer era necesario
volver al lugar volver a las islas la
vida me cruzo con james peck
un hermano de la vida una persona que
cambió mi vida
james está acá entre nosotros es muy
tímido no quiere que los señales pero
nos está acompañando
el vino buenos aires con estos cuadros
el había pintado nuestro sufrimiento
todo el dolor por el cual pasamos los
conscriptos argentinos él lo había
captado capturado en una tela y habían y
nosotros éramos parte de sus propios
fantasmas
la vida nos hermanó bueno james es una
persona muy valiente es una persona con
libertad e independencia de pensamiento
de james recibió el dni argentino de
manos de la presidenta el año pasado yo
tuve el honor de acompañarlo
pero lo que james no me contó en ese
primer viaje donde yo vuelvo con toda mi
familia
era que su papá terrible que había
combatido contra mí
terry había sido el baquiano que guío a
los soldados ingleses hasta donde
estábamos nosotros y terminó combatiendo
a escasos metros nuestros lo conozco en
el año 2000 una persona increíble
nos subimos a los campos de batalla
juntos nos mostramos donde habíamos
estado
brindamos a la memoria de nuestros
compañeros muertos y encontramos terreno
en común donde nos habíamos enfrentado
en una guerra innecesaria
y también nos intercambiamos bobinas
como se ve en esta foto
lo recuerdo con mucho cariño es terry
falleció hace seis años y
y estoy seguro que si él estuviera
viendo esto estaría con la misma sonrisa
que en la foto
una de las postales más emocionantes de
la historia ocurrió en los últimos días
de la guerra
yo voy como intérprete también me
ordenar ir en una patrulla
a una casita que una granja que se
suponía estaba transmitiendo a la flota
por radio
salimos bien temprano estaba congelado
toda la helada era tremenda y estábamos
muy desnutridos ya estábamos mareados
con cualquier desplazamiento me pesaba
el fusil
y llegamos a la casa moribundos ya esta
altura a principios de junio tuvimos un
compañero que se murió de la hipotermia
y la desnutrición antes de que llegaran
los ingleses
y otros cuatro que pisaron una mina en
una de esas caminatas igual que yo y
también murieron
y otros 5 o 6 que se pegaron tiros en
los pies para ser evacuados esa era la
situación terminal en la cual yo llego a
esa casita
y al entrar me alimento con
desesperación
y gritó en inglés a ver si había alguien
y lo primero que me identifica es el
olor de sage de esa casa un olor muy
familiar
y me llama la atención un pulóver inglés
muy lindo que me pongo la nariz y me
conecta con mi propio hogar
y sentí como que alguien dentro de esa
casa que me protegía que me decía ya
falta poco miguel vas a volver vas a
estar bien y cuando me iba con ese
pulóver que me dio me sentí más fuerte
me dio protección
yo dije acá voy a volver algún día y con
esta gente voy a hablar
la vida me dio esta increíble
oportunidad 25 años después se lo
devuelvo a liza el papel pool obrera del
papá
me dijo mi papá murió por el estrés de
esta guerra pocos años después yo le
contesté mi mamá también
un momento sublime cuando nos tomamos
esté con ella cuando nos íbamos con uno
de los isleños en el vehículo 4x4
mientras que usábamos el río me dijo
algo que me llenó el corazón me dijo
sentirse orgulloso miguel estás
construyendo puentes
creo que esa es la clave para cualquier
relación humana construir menos paredes
y más puentes
cuando llegamos al regimiento en la
plata al volver los militares no dieron
arengas nos hicieron firmar
declaraciones juradas para que no
contemos nada y estaban todos los
familiares afuera desesperados por
noticias y los familias de los muertos
que los militares daban formas
informaciones esquivas les decían que
iba a llegar mañana que venían otro
micro y estaban muertos ese recuerdo me
estruja el corazón y desde acá los
abrazo a todos ellos esas familias han
sufrido muchísimo
y me encuentro en la multitud con mi
hermano que también había saltado la
pared del regimiento y me lleva hasta el
auto donde estaban mis viejos
yo voy corriendo por esas calles
adoquinadas de la plata en el frío de
junio
y escuché los gritos de mi vieja y casi
no la veo veo como un aura y me zambullo
entre esos brazos temblorosos
un momento increíble es este este es el
momento más emocionante de mi vida y me
viene a la mente en los momentos duros
de mi vida me viene siempre este flash
y los momentos lindos también es como
una virgen que me acompaña
y yo cuando
cuando volví
mi cuerpo estaba diezmado había perdido
20 kilos tenía los dientes flojos por el
escorbuto el pollito flaco estaba
esquelético los las plantas de los pies
necrosadas por el congelamiento
y
entre en un estado al que yo ahora
razonó como la euforia del sobreviviente
me ponía el despertador temprano
para aunque no tuviera nada que hacer
para disfrutar la vida salía mi cuerpo
destrozado pero estaba con una fortaleza
y una alegría de vivir inmensas y salía
a la calle y todo me emocionaba
profundamente el olor al pasto recién
cortado el canto de los pájaros hasta
los colores de la tele me parecían
emocionantes y la gente que me venía a
visitar me decía che pero estás distinto
estás mejor y yo le decía claro que
estoy mejor pero en ese momento no sabía
cómo explicarlo era esta euforia de
sobreviviente se hizo una fiesta en casa
con amigos y familia vieron náufrago la
de tom hanks bueno cuando él vuelve de
la isla que le hacen una fiesta fue
exactamente igual
yo estaba en otra frecuencia yo venía de
un retiro espiritual venía con todos los
aprendizajes aprendizajes que no se
aprenden en muchas vidas ni en ninguna
universidad
yo venía con esa fortaleza y me sentía
muy fuerte
y en esa fiesta todos tomaban y hablaban
fuerte no
y yo quería estar solo me fui a la
cocina
y prendí la hornalla y así con las manos
calentando de las manos empecé a pensar
para adentro vas a tener que mantener
esta fortaleza porque ellos formas de
amor le pongan les va a costar entender
la profundidad de tu historia vas a
estar solo con este recuerdo toda la
vida y también pensé
si yo puedo congelar esta euforia el
sobreviviente está esta valoración de lo
simple que estoy sintiendo ahora
porque yo veía toda la gente viviendo
vidas como aletargadas expresadas por
cosas materiales
hasta aburridas
y yo estaba con todo este aprendizaje y
estaba consciente de que el ser
consciente de lo preciosa que es la vida
iba a estar mi principal hándicap e iba
a estar mi fortaleza y que iba a tener
una vida distinta y voy a tener una vida
más feliz
30 años después
esta sensación
está intacta
la euforia de sobreviviente está igual
y me da mucho orgullo me llena de
emoción
haber venido hoy a compartir mi euforia
el sobreviviente con todos ustedes
muchas gracias